hi this is des Linden I'll be answering
your questions from Twitter
this is Neurath own support at Germany
Ashley asks looks like I accidentally
goofed up my marathon training schedule
I'm off by a week when is a good time to
skip ahead my advice would be to stay
the course
don't jump ahead don't try to make up
any Fitness when you get to the end I'll
just be a little bit fresher instead of
overcooked dr. David Werner asks
question marathon runners how do you
stay hydrated during a long training run
take a bottle with you visit a shop
short loops via home don't drink or
question question I usually hire a
friend to follow my route and hand me
bottles along the way I like to practice
that pace and just train my gut to take
that fluid in while I'm running I know
that's kind of improbable for a lot of
people so if you get up early and map
your loop out and drop off some bottles
along the way tuck them in the weeds or
hide them off on the side of the road so
that you can grab them as you go that's
a good tip but whatever you do there's a
lot of options it's definitely drink and
practice that in your training don't go
with the last option of don't drink
belly it's and runs asks any tips for
half marathon specific speed work
shooting for a PV yeah I think if you're
already doing a schedule and you have
tempos and speed work built in stay the
course and just keep slowly dialing down
your paces if you're just doing regular
casual runs really great thing to add in
is some strides at the end of the run as
you finish up do a few of those bouts
and that'll add some speed to the legs
and sleeves you finishing feeling fresh
and quick k 2 runs asks professional
runners I'm curious how many a pair of
shoes do you go through and training for
a marathon thanks
I have cushion trainers that I use on
regular runs in marathon training I like
a lighter shoe speed workouts or any
kind of race pace effort I use a racing
flat and then on race day I like a fresh
pair of racing flats so I would say
between 4 to 6 with some good variety in
there at gold medal dad
hey runners what is better for after a
long run
a protein shake for muscle recovery or
sports drink for rehydration electrolyte
balance or both
we've reason why in the comments Cheers
cheers man I would go with the protein
shake within the first 30 to 40 minutes
we need to get that in the body right
away to just help prepare the muscles
that you've broken down throughout a big
long effort hopefully you've hydrated on
the run and so that's pretty well taken
care of as you went but also hydrate
throughout the day too
but for recovery and really repairing
the muscles go with protein first Ellie
asks on a scale of 1 to 10 how stupidest
is it to run a half marathon that you
signed up for went on a runner's high
two months ago and have not practiced
for since asking for a friend she says
it's not a bad idea at all do you go out
and do it actually you can go out and
cover 13.1 just need to adjust your
expectations
maybe temper your goals a little bit
don't go out and try to set a PR that
would be a 10 stupid it's not going to
show up if you haven't put the work in
so if you want to go and have a fun
experience it's a great time to do it
but temper back the expectations at
pheromone asks what do you recommend to
eat before the race I'm confused of what
to wear to my first marathon ever for me
it's super simple bland food is always
kind of the best you want food for
function not for fun and as far as what
to wear I highly recommend checking the
weather because that will make a huge
difference if you're getting ready for
this Falls New York City Marathon plan
if there's going to be rain you want to
shell for when you're out waiting to
start the race and then obviously a you
know comfortable running shorts and a
nice light singlet or kind of a go to if
temperatures are nice spartacus 11 run
asks are running energy gels necessary
for half and full marathons
I'm caffeine intolerance so I avoid all
caffeine what would my alternative be
for long races good question I think you
can take gels without caffeine there's a
lot of options out there with with and
without but I do think having some type
of fuel on the runs necessary for the
longer races you definitely want to be
few
the body so you don't run out of
glycogen late in the race it's commonly
referred to as the bunk and I can attest
to that being no fun at all and another
option as always the hydration fluids
find out what's on the course where
you're racing and maybe practice with
that so you can get your gut adjusted to
how that flavor and taste is gonna work
for you at Kay Webb's asks distance
runners and he thought some barefoot
minimalist running for me with the
amount of work I put in you
traditionally want to have some cushion
under your feet you can rotate in some
barefoot minimalist stuff like strides
after a run barefoot super nice maybe a
couple hundred meter bouts but really I
think we have all these really great
running shoes out there for a reason and
so I'm a big fan of just going with
great shoes alright Meigs asks bit
slower who knows is stamina
long-distance running and ability you
inherit or can I train my body to be
better we can all train our bodies to be
better at long-distance running
most people don't walk out the door and
cover long distances it's something you
build up to it's one of the great sports
that we all find it very difficult at
the beginning just have to put in a
little bit of work Mikayla Whitaker asks
how many hours of sleep do you need to
recover from a marathon 10:00 to 11:00
and night just ain't cutting it wow I am
impressed that you're getting that much
in it takes a while to recover from a
marathon and it's not just sleep I'll
take two weeks snow running and just
kind of forget that I did the marathon
and you know that's resting but also
going out and have some fun oftentimes
runners can come back with low ferritin
or iron
if those stores are low in your body you
can feel really fatigued you would just
look into some supplements or eating a
little bit more red meat or iron in your
diet spinach is a great source as well
so just adding that in might make a
little improvement in your energy levels
Cortney Breton ass
what do people actually do to pass the
time when they're run when they run long
distance I feel like music can only go
so far and I'd be sick of my own
thoughts after about a half mile man you
need to mix it up with some friends some
training partners would be fantastic
books on tape maybe a podcast but really
enjoy being outside I think that's one
of the really great things about running
I love working through my own problems
thinking about nothing thinking about
everything start with a podcast maybe
Emily Ritter can someone teach me how to
get this so-called runner's high I'm
pretty stuck in the runners I want to
die territory that's relatable I think
we all hear the myth of the runner's
high but it's really a hard place to get
to it takes probably 25 30 days to get
in a really great routine the hardest
thing for runners is patience but the
number one tip for runners is be patient
alright I am cat K s recommendations for
running music half marathon training is
going strong but getting bored from of
my playlists think the obvious answer
here is jock jams what else would you
listen to that will hype you up for an
entire run a bead us s at des linden
what are your favorite exercises for
injury prevention in terms of just
general strength they think push-ups are
great sit-ups planks squats are
fantastic to throw in just basic general
body strength things that you can do so
I would recommend all those running
friends you use noti running leases I'm
fine with tying my shoes I do the double
looping swoop and then you tuck then
tuck the laces away so TWU asks so then
runners how often do you foam roll
that's a good question I think that
that's a really great thing to use
before and after a run you can do it
twice a day and if you feel like any
niggling injuries coming on foam roller
is a fantastic place to start also love
the faragon does a little bit of the
same type of thing it's just a little
easier to work timmyyy asked got
hamstring cramp at sixteen point five
miles today
same leg as MK marathon how can I reduce
the chance of that in New York
yeah cramping is the worst I think
staying on top of you know stretching
out and loosening up beforehand consider
a massage just to make sure the muscles
are nice and loose but mostly it comes
down to hydration and electrolytes
hydration is key there at Marty Garcia
13 asks if you didn't put vaseline on
your nipples did you really go running
yes I can attest h asks i have a
question for runners when you're racing
for hours doing a marathon or something
do you need do you ever need to pee they
put toilets out along the route or
that's a question we do have a lot of
time out there and I think we might run
into that problem but there are toilets
all along the route so that's always
helpful to know plumb nanny asks toe
terrible run this morning
how do people deal with a negative
mindset when running I think it might be
my route possibly boring me question
like mix things up try getting a
training partner do your loop backwards
drive somewhere and try some new routes
that's always fun I think obvious answer
here is a great time to go buy a puppy
because dogs love to run too and then
you'll have a dog to take with you if
you take up long-distance running surely
you can eat like a pig question mark
asking for a friend
that's a myth I wish it were true and
sometimes we pretend it's true but
really if you're putting the right
things in go for it Toria asks if I
can't manage a mile on the running
machine then how am I gonna do a half
marathon on a road you have to start
somewhere I think no one is born ready
to run a half marathon we all learn and
train and so start with one mile on the
running machine and then eventually do
two and keep adding it's going to take a
while to get there but that's why it's
so rewarding there's so much to learn
about running and I really appreciate
all the great questions that you guys
sent in thank you for asking